we begin the program in lebanon where a
man who held employees hostage at a bank
in the capital beirut has surrendered
peacefully to police he walked out with
a wave to thousands of people who had
gathered to support him and voiced their
anger about a banking system that's been
accused of misusing funds the man had
entered the bank carrying a gun and
demanded his own money for more on this
let's bring in zaina hoda who's been
covering developments in beirut outside
that bank certainly a relief zainab that
it's been resolved without anyone
getting hurt what happened
well a peaceful end to this hour's long
hostage situation a negotiated
settlement is what ended this standoff
this is what we understand from the
family of bassam
the man who walked in to that bank
behind me at 11 am beirut time
holding a gun and demanding his own
money he has 210 000 us dollars in his
account he hasn't been able to access
that
for the past three years banks have
imposed capital controls and when you do
withdraw some money you significantly
reduce the value of your deposits
because uh people really are facing a
haircut now he laid down his arms after
this negotiated settlement what we
understand he he was given approximately
35 000 us dollars he was demanding money
in fact he visited the bank in the past
in recent days um demanding five
thousand dollars he wanted money to pay
for his father's hospital bill and the
bank refused to give him that money so
he reached breaking points and he was
very disgruntled angry and he entered
the bank so it's now over but the crisis
in lebanon is not over as you mentioned
many people came here to support him to
say that their money too is trapped in
banks and many people are struggling to
make ends meet
all right thank you very much for that
update zayna hoda with all the
developments out of beirut